I just tell her. He's This is some legendary gameplay right here.
This guy does some Oh.
I'm going to bait him with Willy Mac questions and then ask him
about his Iron Fist gameplay. He He predicted it. He kind of
won, okay? I just want to ask this guy like two questions about
his coverage, but he's like he's not going to join now. I watched
his Iron Fist gameplay. He will not He He just can't take it.
And it's it's embarrassing and it's I'm ob He's on a five-win
streak before you start watching me, just to be fair. I
And that is weakness. And so, probably that's just not the strategy,
Kelly. He like he didn't say anything. You didn't talk him. What
do you you have short-term memory? I was on the stream with you
when you [__] talked him. Where? Where? Where? Where?
Where? Where? Where? When? Where? When?
Uh sorry, Kelly, for being an Oh, rare. Okay. Thank you. I actually
I What are you talking about? I literally always apologize when
I'm an
I never got an the issue is you keep doing the
when I beg you to do something else that's less than And Kelly
does what? Kelly never does an [__] thing ever? No, Kelly
gets mad at you being an
Yes, obviously.
Please be Please be somebody.
Meraal, what's up? Are you able to talk at all? Isn't your internet
working? It's like accumulating.
But I thought they weren't a for 17,
I'm just saying it cuz it's funny and because Destiny doesn't
want us calling him a So, I'm just going to call everyone a
Whatever. I don't care. certainly wouldn't have any leg to stand
on if he criticized you for it, so.
It is what it is.
Meraal, is your internet working
Why are we e-logging Kweiman again? Just let him It's not e-logging.
You can't say it's e-logging to just watch his gameplay. it's
e-logging. He's really good at the game, isn't he? said it. What
is What is going on here?
I'm only changing content. No, not really. Who is that aimed
at now?
He's actually so bad. He's going to get this guy that he just
got the full drop on, came in right behind them as a DPS. Oh,
no, he's actually going to just [__] GET
THAT WAS ROUGH, WASN'T IT? I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS PRETTY ROUGH.
That was pretty That was pretty brutal. someone who is projecting.
It has to
I get mad because it's funny.
Also, because people are annoying and stupid. He's totally going
to nail his dive this time, guys. He's got it. He's landed one
ability so far. Now he's in the middle of the enemy and HE IS
WHAT IS HE DOING?
KELLY, prove you're not a right now. Really something else. Am
I supposed to ask every child if I've done anything I know that
he will be able to land a kill this time. [__] you,
Kelly.
Very unlikely.
Okay. Well, whatever you say. 40, dude. You're out of You're
out of my I've spent more time with you over the past year than
any other man in your entire life. So, I really feel like you
saying unlikely or more unlikely for me seems pretty crazy, okay?
I mean, I never said either was
Are you more of a tomorrow?
Yeah, definitely. I hope so. I'd like to think so.
All right. Well, go to the gym and get some sleep. than me? What
the hell? Uh I run a I run a 26-minute 5K. What are you talking
about get faster?
I can definitely run a 5K faster than
What's a 5K?
Uh five running 5,000 m. Is that a thing? Oh, okay.
I don't know what you guys are talking about who's more of a
I'm very confused.
It's joking. I just hate being British sometimes because I'm
so incredibly funny and destined to be under-appreciated by [__]
mouth-breathing idiots.
Wait, when have I ever under-appreciated how funny you are, Kelly?
Well, you do and Kweiman does. Everyone else is What is Kweiman
doing? Why is he just running on the ceiling? What the [__]
is this? He's really good at this game, actually, I think. He
just like ulted or something and he definitely didn't just get
stunned and mugged. OH, HE'S GOING TO GET BACK IN. HE'S just
dead again.
I think Is that supposed to happen when you like ult and then
you like get covered in like green [__] and you just
charge at a guy and do like two damage and then don't get a I
feel like that's probably not a good
I played one round of this game and then uninstalled it. You're
asking the wrong
He's going to get some damage done. He's getting Mr. Fantastic
[__] up. Gets the healing pack.
He's still getting dead again.
Have I seen him get a kill on stream
I'm not even joking. Have we witnessed a kill on stream yet or
I don't I actually don't know. Surely. Oh, wait. One in six right
now. One in six. There's one Yeah, there's one I don't know if
I got it, but
To be fair, let's let's just be real. Does anybody Can Kweiman
actually complain about this in any way when he like watches
Tommy C and other stupid all the time? I feel like
I feel like no. This has to be against This has to be allowed,
right? Okay, this has to be it. This is it. He's got this person.
He's green. He's green. HE'S GOT THE DAMAGE.
DID HE GET THE I CAN'T TELL IF HE GOT THE IT SEEMED LIKE he bounced.
His health is so high. Why would he bounce? That's so weird.
He's dead. Jesus.
I can't tell. Hopefully he hits tab and we'll see if he's two
in six now. Two in seven, sorry.
This is What he meant by e-logging.
Uh hold on. We're getting there. We're getting there. We're getting
there.
You have no idea what you're looking at, but sure. What do you
think I'm confused about what I'm looking at? Where have I been
incorrect in anything I'm saying? You've never played this game
before.
His team somehow not lost despite
Oh, he's got him. HE'S GOT HIM. HE'S GOT I think that was a That
was a Right?
That was a That was a He finished that. He finished that. He's
got to be on the point. Okay, they lost.
Oof. That's got to be two to zero and they lose the round, right?
Three three to eight. So, he got both of those at the end. He
got both of those at the end that we were thinking he might not
have gotten.
You were wrong that I'm going green is ultimate? Is that what
I said? What do you mean?
Does it not seem like his ultimate?
Okay, I think I got a This got to be our last round we watch.
I don't think I can watch anymore. I think that would be very
painful.
That's how people feel when they watch this stream. Was that
a 19-point loss? That's rough. That's rough.
Rose is running out the clock. Sorry, I was Yeah, I'm just running
out the clock. Meraal, did you watch the Willy Mac video?
Um what did you think of it?
Uh there were good parts.
There were some good parts, for sure. I think he put in probably
three to five times the effort he put into the first video.
I think I agree with that.
I think there are some parts where he's obviously like insanely
either bad faith
uh where it kind of took me out. I was like, "Okay." Like the
notably the
the infinite machine thing.
I think I
I listened to his his take on the infinite machine and I was
like, "Dude, this This is
This sucks to listen to." Wait, what did you What do you think
the infinite machine is?
It's like a girl's every day
and then you have the chance to speak out about it, but the girl
doesn't want you to speak out about it or whatever. Do you speak
out about it and when or whatever, it's right? Something like
Um Okay, the president Sunday not making clear. Something like
that. I don't Something like that. What did he say? It's really
funny that the hypothetical is like quite literally Sundays.
It's quite literally like Sunday's hypothetical that he came
up with and he
I believe has talked about in like multiple places.
And Willy just didn't know that.
I wasn't referencing his hypothetical.
Uh it was something to do with what Nick was talking about on
stream.
Which was?
Oh, he was arguing with Augie about why Willy Mac's video was
good.
He was arguing with Augie
Yeah, he got mugged pretty hard. Willy Mac's video was good.
And then you brought up infinite machine. I don't How do those
relate? Uh because they're probably talking about the president
why you have to talk about President Sunday or why President
Sunday did what he did. And it's like, well, you could engage
or not engage, but like he has an argument of basically by allowing
Destiny continue, you're allowing a pattern of behavior to continue
that will lead to more women getting victimized.
And so
he will sacrifice one woman to put a to throw a wrench in the
cogs of the infinite machine. Was the general Sunday
So that but but if you don't engage with that, if you just say
Sunday's like a ludicrous like a delusional maniac, it's like
well, that's not really engaging with like the argument or almost
It's not really yeah, engaging at all. I
a delusional maniac.
That doesn't mean he's not capable of like cognizant thought.
Sure. But I mean you can engage with his reason for publishing
the video or not. If you don't engage at all with his reason
for publishing the video, like like I don't know what we're doing.
Like why why talk about it, right? His reason for publishing
the video, like if you or I mean, if you want to have a conversation
about it, you should actually talk about it, right? Like is it
okay to to violate one person's consent to try to take down like
a a machine that has hurt a lot of people that you know about
or something, right? That is broadly what the argument is. And
that's I don't know exactly why I was referencing it. I didn't
see there, but I do know I'm referencing Sunday's hypothetical
that he talked about. Right? And then I say that's like Sunday's
hypothetical. I literally say it there.
So I just find it funny that I'm referencing somebody else's
hypothetical and Willy uses that make a point he could maybe
try to make. But like
yeah, I think that point could be far more easily or far more
accurately made about Chud Logic and DK.
And but I didn't hear him make it about them. I heard him like
in
what would you call it? Dis-ingenuously make it about me.
Which is very in I think he has a a very big hate boner for you
and um Queenman for some reason.
Um Uh the funny thing is is I literally tried to take it easy
on him. I literally tried to like step down and not go after
him and
I made that like pretty clear multiple times. And I got I got
no credit for that. That's a stop.
Credit Chud and DK engage in machine behavior. I don't
Uh You said it's more multiple thumbnails from Chud called based
about the word in there.
Yeah, but that's not what it's about, right? You just said the
the hypothetical was just about understanding Willy's criticism
genuinely Willy's criticism is because Jstock called it that
that makes everybody think not take this seriously.
I didn't Oh, okay. That's not me calling it. That's me talking
about a hypothetical that he talked about. should have left you
saying or something.
Um even he I think would be and he would get on that as well.
But um yeah, But it would be more relevant.
It'd be more relevant. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yep. Yeah, he could
have tried to find a relevant clip and he didn't.
And that one makes him look completely
Especially because through covering the Sunday stuff, you should
be aware of the infinite machine hypothetical, right?
Yeah, so I just don't understand what the excuse of like um not
warning the woman before you sacrifice them is.
Uh it's irrelevant to the point of like the criticism of Willy
Mac, so.
Uh no, I yeah, I'm talking about President Sunday's. I don't
I don't get it.
But like if you're going to sacrifice a woman in the name of
the destroying the infinite machine, you could at least give
her a heads up first.
Oh, does he not I guess he no longer calls it the infinite machine
in the video, right? But the video is the abuse machine, the
Destiny abuse machine.
Which he I guess before that maybe maybe Willy Mac might not
know that the infinite machine is the same thing that that's
Sunday's hypothetical.
Yeah, surely it's going to be easy to get that information to
him now that you've called him
He is a Surely that will go away. reason The only reason you're
trying to show any charity to him is because he talked to you.
No, it's because he gets upset and you know about this because
you've seen his behavior, right? Sometimes you have to change
your behavior to like be able to communicate with other people.
I hold on. I changed my behavior. I said, hey, you know what?
I He took the video where I said, hold on, shut the [__]
up for 2 seconds. He took the video where I said, you know what,
Willy? I actually communicated poorly. I actually communicated
poorly and here's like what the actual criticisms would be. And
you know what? Whatever, buddy. Right? He took that video where
I'm like, oh, this is me actually communicating poorly and here's
the actual criticisms and he took the part where I was like,
oh, I didn't quite watch like I didn't watch the whole thing.
I just watched the sections I criticized you on. And he took
that and was like, he didn't watch the whole video yet. He's
a
Fragile men and children. Second
Sure, but I I just let it go. So now I feel like I just don't
I don't really
I just think letting it go is fug. Yeah, I let it go through
him whining about it through multiple Twitter threads, yes.
Yes, you whine about it just in a different way.
Nope. I just said You're both whiny and annoying. Like You're
both whiny and annoying. You are. You can communicate with each
other.
That is what she sounds like. You both have your own You're both
whiny and
You could Yeah, I just You could That just You're half the reason
why. You're half the reason why.
Stop doing that. You sound stupid. Stop it. Stop it. I'm on Kelly's
side here. You sound like a Jstock.
Uh Kelly Kelly, I'm on Kelly's side here. Kelly, what are you
doing later? You want to come on my stream?
I'm on the Kelly asked and she said no. side here. I already
tried to get her on. She said no. She said no. You want to come
on my stream? Okay, you just want to be in my DMs, Kelly? Kelly
Kelly. She's already in my DMs.
You know like This is not working out for you, Jstock. of the
video where Willy Mac edited like the really high-pitched screaming
noise. How I feel.
Yeah. You made that noise where I just said I shot a zombie in
my game.
Kelly, do you want to be I think some of some of my my biggest
issues
with Willy's video
You know what an infinite factory is,
A what?
Is that what it's called? What is it called? It's infinite factory,
right? Isn't that what you play?
Okay, what's the game you play is you're putting the factories
together? Uh Satisfactory?
Maybe it's Satisfactory.
Three-dimensional factory building game. Yeah, Satisfactory.
Okay, I like it. Do you like factories? I'll play it with you.
No, I don't like factories.
I find it funny when you have women that want to play women if
they want to play factory game though. I do find that quite funny.
I got one of my women friends to
to play it with me.
Uh and she did not
she did not understand why I did. And I've not gotten her to
play it
Um hm.
Yeah, I'm trying to think of like the what he called the content
cop video, what are the criticisms I'd have. I'd just say broadly
like the pattern of abuse there, the I think you have to start
including um just in general this guy's like prick He said that
at the end he was like, I don't think there's a pattern here
and then he goes on to explain the pattern. He's like, Stacia,
Cherry, Pixie, Blue
He's like, I don't think there's a pattern and then he lists
like everyone and it's like, okay, you don't think there's a
pattern, but then you list like Yeah, I think it would be I think
it would be like people who cross him and then you'd have to
include a couple of the people. Yeah, I think the Kick Chat went
out there, guys. I don't know if you were having issues with
Kick Chat. That like if you look at my Kick Chat logs and it's
funny how you can see Kick's like total non-viability as a chat
platform as like a 5-minute interval goes by where we have 65
chatters and 67 chatters in a 5-minute interval and then there's
two chatters in the previous 5-minute interval. Like, are you
serious?
Are you serious? Then it goes down to 10, 50 chatters, goes down
to 10.
Who cares about this? Why?
Who cares about Kick Chat breaking constantly? Me? Yeah, you
care about this. You care about this.
Yeah, you do. Do you need to broadcast it?
Uh well, most of the chat gets kind of annoyed when Kick Chat
breaks for no
Kelly, you're such a freaking negative Nancy sometimes, you know
that? Negative Nancy.
Who asked?
I'm just I'm talking out loud. Yeah, don't.
They're annoying.
Uh what else was there? I guess um playing that Cherry audio
that was leaked was kind of a weird choice,
I thought it was weird how he
he basically insinuated that Destiny was indeed sending people
to Anna's docs on Kiwi Farms. And then he said, hey, here's the
audio from Cherry and here's where I find it. I was like, okay,
this is like I Like he didn't have to say that from Kiwi Farms.
Like that's I
Yeah, I don't I don't think he did. It was pretty bizarre.
I
But I I said like I don't know if I can criticize that. Like
I feel like I'm really close to that, so I'm going to try to
hold off of saying like this is like disgusting think Yeah, I
don't think that's I don't know if it's like Maybe including
the actual audio, I don't know. But I Including the actual audio
saying where you got it from and then saying Kelly Jean sent
me there, Kelly Jean sent me it. It's like okay, I
I think he could have just said like in the audio leak, here's
what the audio is. Like this is proof because of this reason.
Like I think that would have been better. I think saying where
it's from nothing specific to Kiwi Farms. Like if this was on
Instagram, like I think if he said it was from Instagram and
showed where to get it. Like I think that so would have been
pretty odd. So I think he could have just said like in the audio
leaked and here's a bit of it to prove what I'm saying is real.
I think that would have been fine. I just feel weird about him
saying like where it where it is. I don't even know. I feel like
he could say like the audio leaked and it is like it does show
this.
But maybe like he has a play but that would be perfectly fine,
yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
I just I feel like if I had a YouTube channel, listen, I don't
have a YouTube channel for a reason. But if I had a YouTube channel,
I probably wouldn't take like a legit like revenge audio
and put it in my video. I just probably wouldn't do that. I I
also wouldn't be illegal recording that I say is illegal.
Yeah, I like that that's basically I I'm sitting here and I'm
like wait, what what's the point you're trying to make? I Is
it that this is illegally recorded? That this is like a felony
audio recording and you're going to leak part of it?
Um Yeah, yeah. I
I if we're going to talk about like he's like I wouldn't call
somebody a cuz I don't want to get sued. And I'm like, well,
I don't know. Probably I wouldn't like I wouldn't put like supposedly
non-consensually recorded audio of a interaction my video. Now
there is no part there, so maybe that's a little misleading.
I won't say that, but
I mean the actual issue will be, right, if Cherry or Denims decide
to say yikes, why is this in that? And can they strike for this?
I have no f- clue. Because that's the thing he's like putting
himself at risk for. I don't I don't know.
Um yeah, I don't know.
My biggest issue isn't like a point in the video, so maybe this
is a bit um but I just thought it was boring, it was way too
long and it was a
a drag to watch.
Jesus. I think there were like a bunch of good parts in it. I
think most of Anna's stuff was good.
I think I'd rather I think yeah, I just like the hash.
God, if only I could get to like vocalize just how much of a
drag everyone else has all of the time. But like I think he did
a good job with Anna's stuff. No, no, I'm not okay.
Are you good? Um but I I interrupted you. Have I upset you? Kelly,
are you good? God, I wish I could just kick you like a
What the [__] have I done? What I'm so confused.
Why are you upset with me?
Jesus, tough crowd. Yeah, Spudgun, I
I think um
I yeah, whatever. It's it is what it is, okay. It is what it
is on that front. No, it was just nice to see like Anna get decent
like ability to speak. Can't say what she want to say, right?
It was just good and I'm glad that yes. And I like the live stuff
was decent,
Some of the bits were all right.
Yeah, I thought there were good parts of the video, definitely.
I think it was better than the previous
Um him using the Cherry tweets to talk me I thought was kind
of in poor taste, but hey. After I think he is a a spiteful loser.
I really don't like Willy Mac. I think the past these two Destiny
videos have shown me I really don't like this guy.
I'm sure he cries at night about that.
Sure, this did happen as well and we somebody pointed this out.
Yeah, he said Pixie's not
naked in the video and it's like there are DMs between Pixie
and Destiny where she says like I'm going to tell people that
my breasts don't look like that and that's like my proof that
it's not me.
Like literally how would she be saying that if she wasn't naked
in the video?
Yeah, Destiny is incredibly rely on on the fact that he says
so many lies at once that to rule all of them out is going to
take someone who's very effective at that and I just yeah.
And worse still, for that particular lie, well, Willy Mac would
just get a have to go search revenge
to like figure that out, all right. So it's like
I don't know.
This doesn't even actually say but I think sick sick like maybe
not the right person. Somebody sent me a sick tweet.
Let's see here. Hold on.
Uh you lied about the nakedness. You lied about Destiny post
is illegal Denims recording through you. It's this one. Did Destiny
get away with saying he's never sent porn where the other person's
a focal point?
Did he say that? I think he said he never sent videos with other
people um only other people. And it's like he's only sent videos
where he participates.
I don't know if this one was correct.
I don't know if I think this one's correct necessarily.
I mean what I will say is I didn't catch the Pixie lie until
the third time watching it, right? And I know he's lying and
it was me that said it. You didn't pick it up either, okay? So
like he lies so much
that you really do have to be on your
Wait, who said the Pixie lie?
I'm sorry, Destiny said the Pixie lie. You didn't notice it,
I did. But that's only after watching it three times.
Uh sure, okay.
So yeah. What you're saying is you'd never be in
recordings at the center of a non-consensual sharing case. Um
yeah, I don't know. I've never done that. I thought about like
trying to do that personally and I was like, oh, I probably can't
do it. Like and by the way I I didn't want to do it where the
person involved was not identified.
That was in the gay [__] recording, right? I don't
want to do it where the person involved is not identified at
all. Doing it where the person's identified seems kind of weird,
but
yeah, I don't I don't know. I don't know if I'm the person to
make the argument.
I mean on the plus side, it does show that Destiny looks like
an idiot for saying, oh, that was on the nightstand.
No, it wasn't.
It's like if something's sitting on a nightstand, it doesn't
rustle like it's in a
Uh for sure.
Hold on, I'm sending a message here. If you could take over two
seconds, Kelly.
Uh take over
take over.
Well, that's just my line.
And before Willy calls everyone obsessed and say, okay, it was
impossible to know everything about Destiny. Okay, yes, but he's
a very reactive person. Destiny all knows this and is also a
reactive person and they're both idiots when they could just
speak like normal people, but they won't. Because they're men.
That's the biggest problem. They're both just men.
I let this
lie about me for a whole bunch of time. I didn't correct him.
I didn't go after him. I just let him be a spiteful for like
weeks and he has taken that as weakness. And so probably that's
just not the strategy, Kelly, okay? say anything. You did talk
him. Where? You you you have short-term memory. I was on stream
with you when you said
Where? Where? Where? Where? Where? Where? Where? When? Where?
When?
Are you trying to imply you didn't say anything about Willy Mac
on your stream?
I'm implying that I went weeks going, we're not going to fight
with Willy Mac. We're not going to fight with Willy Mac. We're
not going to fight with Willy Mac. That's true. I did.
Okay, it might not be fighting, but saying a bunch of comments
on your breath all the time. You know, they just everyone's getting
to see and hear things. I just
Okay. That's not true. I mean that's very disingenuous.
I'm not saying you don't have the right to like as well Why should
I criticize his video that badly, Kelly?
Pointing out that he just maliciously lied about me. This seems
like a probably not good, right? Okay. Why should I have to Why
should I do a Why should I do Okay, so what you're saying is
he's a lazy or is he a he is a lazy hack loser. Don't you think
those two things is going to bother him more? I'm sure both is
the answer.
I'm also sure he is both a liar and a lazy hack loser. No, both
will annoy him and you're just both annoying each other. So it's
just you just sound like everyone who bullies Lock her in my
Discord. You're both annoying. I don't want to intervene anymore.
Just go be annoying to each other in a gay closet somewhere.
I don't
I believe I Bro, LGBT
There may be a I am
your lesbian. I'm B.
You're trans?
We've been live just rated.
Come here.
We've been live no way. I didn't know we were live this whole
time. What?
You guys know we were live this what was he streaming about?
Hold on. I see what he was streaming about. I just want to kill
all of you. Actually you know what I agree with you guys. Oh
he's playing he's playing Marvel Rivals. Okay. He's playing Marvel
Rivals
How did this go?
Hold on.
Let's go to check real quick.
Okay, he's playing a different character
He was he was actually just towering. He's so gay.
This is some legendary gameplay right
Oh boy.
This guy does some oh
Hold on. Hold on. He's doing much better in this one. 17 12.
Are you still just like he just rated. I just was around. It's
fine. It's fine.
He's not here. If he was here he'd be in the Discord. Okay.
He's not here. If he would be here we would be here. Like great
observation.
Not here well the guy was saying he was watching. I don't think
he's watching.
I just want to ask this guy like two questions about his coverage
but he's like he's not going to join now. I watched his Iron
Fist gameplay. He will not he he just can't take it.
He knew he knew I was going to bait him with Willy Mac questions
and then ask him about his Iron Fist gameplay. He he predicted
it. He kind of won. Okay.
And it's it's embarrassing. It's I'm all I had a five win streak
before you started watching me. Like I like
Uh You asked me about the Willy Mac thing. I I'm kind of still
playing Rivals like I want to but I don't Okay. Um oh I was just
going to say Did you notice that he didn't understand the infinite
machine was a Sunday
Did you see that at the end? Yeah I was just like Yeah I did.
I just thought that was Uh I went and found the clip and I literally
say within like five seconds of the clip that he posted like
that it's a Sunday hypothetical and that I'm talking about
I saw the insult at me Queenman.
When he was saying oh Willy Mac can't understand this concept
but Kelly can I and she's a
Something along those lines. I don't know if I said quite like
I don't know if I said quite like that. I mean the implication
was a very It might have been it might have been so the implication
It might have been. Who would imply Kelly is
or can't understand hypothetical? That would be a very very very
mean thing to
Because I will remember it forever and make sure to disprove
it.
You notice Nicholas DeOrio is watching the Willy Mac video right
now. Oh yeah. Oh okay. This is my favorite part though. Okay.
This is my favorite part. You see a screenshot right Queenman?
Or wait you don't. It's the uh it's the straight rate Destiny
DMs. Okay.
And he talks to Destiny and there's a yellow highlighted part
that's like you didn't even leak it at all. You should have just
said it was Destiny.
Yes the well oh hey lol I know I violated your trust in the worst
way ever. Okay. You pointed that out. Okay cuz I was like that
was like I'm like dude if you had just read the rest of the paragraph
you would have the exact question to ask him right now. It's
insane that you
I I call I call it fully too much. I thought it's it isn't it
isn't epic and
I thought the video was good overall. I thought it was Yes. That's
what I said as well just to call it because he's a man you're
not listening to it. What I said too. Hold on. I said the video
was mostly good and he put like three to five times more effort
in than he did in the last one. I said it was like I'd personally
like 7.5 you know.
7.5 on a general tier or on the Willy Mac tier? On a general
tier. Like a 7.5 Destiny video. I think like the Ryan Beard one's
like a nine. Willy's like 7.5.
You know. I so and maybe you can maybe give me your opinion on
this. I personally thought um taking the audio from a non-consensual
like encounter and putting that in your video
pointing that that to me I knocked like a point and a half off
for that. Um this one I thought was pretty bad to not get this
or not I thought this is pretty bad that like you have the video
or that you have the thing up but I get I guess maybe if you
are asking the moment right. It's not it's not just that. He
put like the the like censor main screenshots in there as well
which I mean I guess they're on Destiny's stream. It's like
I know. I think that's way different than Destiny's stream. I'm
saying that same with like belly sensitive.
Basically somebody's crotch. Crazy. Jesus.
Um and then I just thought like the
for some reason like maliciously oh and then saying that there's
no pattern of behavior here. I thought that was a bold It's cuz
he just doesn't he doesn't even know what the pattern is. He
just can't even he can't even I don't think he knows. He doesn't
have pattern recognition you know.
So I thought between failing to understand the pattern or pointed
out at all Um and I think I think the thing that made him not
understand the pattern was just being asked mad about you and
Like the doxing stuff he points out but then he doesn't include
that in the pattern like the pattern isn't I don't think about
abusing women.
It seems to be more of a pattern about how he handles I don't
know if that sent is the right word or being challenged is the
right word.
It's like a way he handles certain kinds of um engagement where
he is just willing to go balls to the wall to like destroy you.
Seems seems to me.
Uh the Anna section was good. I like that quite a bit.
Oh boy.
Completely ignores the actual logs of
Are you talking about Maximus?
He plays the clip where he says he wants
do what?
Oh the attempt to oh also he doesn't know that the doxing released
or maybe he just didn't say it cuz he didn't want to point to
it. But then the cherry thing the the audio thing just makes
me think that that wouldn't have been okay for him at all.
So I think the end the pattern of like oh these people were that
like he he thinks he doxed them and now he's calling for their
death and being like super specific about it. I think that's
pretty crazy.
I don't know. I didn't like it but I was nitpicking pretty hard.
I also really don't like Willy Mac and I'm not going to act like
I was being entirely good
while watching it. Uh I I think I said three to five times more
and it's like a way better video and that like there's large
good sections of it. I didn't like that he totally maliciously
framed one of my arguments and then use it to like
use it to try to say that like I'm making people not take it
seriously with the word
I thought that was insane.
And the failure to understand the pattern. So
I think yeah I brought up the thing I brought up the
the [__] pattern thing cuz I thought the pattern
thing was like super [__]
Like he says like I don't see a pattern and then he goes on like
directly after to name everyone that Destiny's ever [__]
like [__] with and it's like okay what a What is
this dude?
Yeah I think it's a better video. I don't know if it would be
7 and a half
if Ryan's is a nine. I think um
I mean maybe. I don't know. I just dude
can't stand
Willy's videos. I just find them so annoying to watch. They're
just so boring to me.
So I I mean in terms of watchability I I take it down like a
point at least. I just I don't know.
I think I feel I feel bad a little
because I do think that probably
his disdain for me led to him having like no concern for Cherry
whatsoever and just like trying to use her as a cudgel.
I don't know. I don't know. That's
sort of like you using the tweets to like get a shot in at me
and then but posting her audio it just seems like probably I
think that mostly had to do with him not liking me. And not really
him thinking about whether or not
He's super super super vindictive.
Oh hold on. We got a we got a brand new clip from Mr. Nicholas
DeOrio that I feel like Arc is setting me up with
I just got linked this.
Um Nicholas believes that they took Ichigo's sword because it
had a swastika on it.
it's a dog whistle took a situation where they're being called
anti-Semitic and posed with a sword they view as a swastika sword.
That was on purpose.
Listen, he he might have bought it for that reason.
Yeah, why does the audience become such a dog pile? It's crazy.
What is going
Are you sure you Are you sure you want to be saying that? You
You want to get clipped by Arc again, Queenman? Are you sure?
Are you sure? It's just facts. I'm sorry, I'm Jewish. I'm Jewish.
I'm facts. He said facts there. It's This guy has had his little
mind warped by Ethan Klein. It's It's pretty crazy. It's a bleach
sword, buddy. Well, hold on. What if Hassan is like, "Oh, this
is cool. This is a swastika sword." What if he says this is "Oh,
W Hitler." What if he says "W Hitler"?
No
way, dude.
Hassan said it was a little sus.
That's He's Nazi.
Oh my god. way. He gestures down toward
This one's sicker, dude.
It's sus, bro. Why is it sus?
bag Okay.
Immediately goes to the swastika one.
It was on purpose.
He did it on purpose.
I'm sorry. I think they did it on purpose. That's my personal
opinion.
Uh they knew it looked like a swastika.
And I You know what this is, right? This is Aristocracy's been
in his DMs. This is uh
They posed with it. And it's contagious, Dude, they did it on
purpose.
No, that's how I view it now. That's my personal opinion on this.
It's a dog whistle. Dude, these guys Dude, I'm sorry, bro. We've
watched videos where people have called this dog whistler and
[__] like this for years by these exact types of
people. They took a situation where they're being called
uh anti-Semitic and they
posed with a sword that they view as the swastika sword. That
was on purpose,
Do not even argue with me about this. This is ridiculous. Immediately
goes to the swastika one. Got it. I like this already much better.
That's amazing. That's amazing.
What What is this guy on, man? What is
No, I'm I'm just like I'm waiting for the the massacre to come
crashing down at this point. I can't This much further. I feel
like this clip was posted intentionally to clip us watching it
and laughing at it so that Arc could cook, okay? I think that's
what happened here. I'm pretty sure.
Uh just for my peace of mind, Jan being Jewish neuroticism, right?
Yeah. Uh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good. All right. Wasn't sure it was Wasn't sure. 100% sure.
Yeah. Maybe Hassan just doesn't know what bleach is. Maybe Do
you think he bought this and he just doesn't know what bleach
is?
He may well not, but I guarantee I know bleach is.
Do not even argue with me about this. This is ridiculous. Immediately
goes to the swastika one. Got it. I like this already But he's
got a lot of anime stuff there. Like he He watched One Piece.
He did go on that anime podcast a couple of times. He's got that
Demon Slayer thing there. That guy is Hold on. I don't know.
Maybe Yeah, yeah. Wait, are we only looking at Wait, hold on.
Somebody send me Somebody's got to be able to find it. Where's
the Where's the bottom It's online with the sword.
What is this place? I don't know. He probably wanted to dab when
the queen died, to be honest with you.
What is this? He sent this clip. What is this clip? Cuz my parents
won't let me. So there was like a lot of like within these messages
sort of tone indicators that this is a very young person. So
when someone says OnlyFans, they're spreading a piece of misinformation
in his bed. I agree. That That is a piece of misinformation,
yeah. benefit. Because if she did do OnlyFans, we could say well,
but this website, which is known for verifying people's identity
and age, says she's 19. Therefore, it's reasonable to think that
she's 19.
But I will say, I think that if this person is 18 years old,
meandering this argument is completely irrelevant. This is like
a single sentence at best type talking point. It's too convoluted.
Okay. an argument. And if she lied about her age, I'm probably
not going to hold him accountable unless I see evidence
is very obvious that she's like Yeah, but he Do you not understand
that it's really funny to say Destiny paid for
And then he has to accept that we can just say that.
That would be really children lie. I'm an adult. You don't make
them take responsibility.
Good job. Uh there's a degree, but if she was like 17 years old
and 10 months, I feel like there's just I'm Sorry, I'm not really
that concerned about it. Okay, so what if she's It's just more
funny to without it being defamation to just be able to say Destiny
paid for
It's just a dumb thing. You You guys get three months buffer.
I get three months buffer. It's uh Man, I can't have this conversation
with men cuz you're so
all of you. Cuz all of you are just worried about oh, actually
well, I might have gotten that in the
It's just annoying.
It's all right as a tall. Yes, it is. It's just like when someone
lies. All of you are like "I don't like I don't like those rules
being that strict cuz that might like impact me and gooning habits.
Why else would you
Uh okay. I mean, I don't talk to 17-year-olds, so I'm good. Ralph
So why not make a harsh line? Why you got to have a buffer?
Um because I don't know. should should go down for her allegations
right now,
The girl confirmed
Okay, well, where it's grooming is legal when you're a woman.
Jean would never
she should not be listened to in
That's That's not very nice, Cajun. Just grade a woman's story
just saying it's crazy. No, she has been crazy for a
And this is not the first crazy thing that she said. Maybe Emaru
targets her because she's because she's crazy. Maybe Emaru targets
her cuz she's vulnerable. One of the stuff where oh, Emaru knew
me when I was underage. She was literally dating Diarus at the
time. She was not doing anything inappropriate or stupid.
What if she was being inappropriate?
DMs and voice chats. Well, okay. So she You're saying like she
was secretly cheating on Diarus.
No, but just
and stuff like that like could be bad, right? That's bad.
I'm not saying what
But apparently she's talking about like
The quote I saw was it said she was
The 17-year-old.
Is that it? I don't know. I haven't looked into it.
I said I don't care if she's 17. It's had the type of things
that people vocalize I wish I had never heard. But that doesn't
make it traumatizing. I don't want to know when anyone is horny,
but I still unfortunately get it thrust upon me by existing on
the internet. What What if Destiny told a 17-year-old that he
was horny?
Then he shouldn't, but like what is the point you're making here?
Wait, wait, wait. all that Destiny was doing, we wouldn't be
having this conversation.
I just realized another incredibly important point from this
video that I have to test with you guys, okay? WillyMac has objectively
done every single thing in this video that Destiny wants me and
Queenman for and docs for, right? So Destiny has Now, he is literally
forced to apply the standard,
Cuz he doesn't have any standards. Willy literally apparently
played audio from Revenge porn of Destiny. Um he cited a website
where you could find those videos or so so that audio, right?
Yeah, I I Well, I realize he has no standards, but come on, man.
Lean into it for a second.
Sorry, no standards.
What did you just say? Well, obviously.
It was a joke about how obviously this like did literally everything
Destiny wants to clip us for.
What's up, Destiny? What's going?
Hi. And get Nicholas in here. We have to We have to hold a We
have to hold Yeah, we are live. We have to hold a an intervention,
okay?
Is Is his coverage very bad? He's been infected. No, no, no,
no, I mean, I'm sure his coverage of the WillyMac video is fine.
he's been infected with the Jewish neuroses, okay? We have TO
SAVE HIM. WOAH. WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT, BUDDY?
Um he thinks that he thinks Destiny thinks that Jewish people
have like a proclivity to be like more neurotic and anxious Yeah, histrionic
would be the word I use. other people. Yeah, exactly. people
shouldn't be the ones speaking about that. Not histrionic, but
I I actually
agree probably with that assessment. I actually think that's
totally valid.
We need to get We need to get this guy
They're controlling his brain again.
He thinks the uh the iDubb sword, the Bleach sword
that iDubb and Hasan chose it for
it having a swastika. They're like, "This is They're like W The
dog whistle to that. He actually There's no no shot Yeah, he
does. He does.
Yeah, watch. Jump in the presentation. Jump in the presentation
if you don't believe it. All right.
No way, dude.
No f- way. He gestures down toward it.
This one's sicker, dude.
It's sus, bro. Why is it sus? Questionable. Questionable.
Bag. Oh, okay.
Immediately goes to the swastika one,
It was on purpose.
They did it on purpose.
I'm sorry. I think they did it on purpose. That's my personal
opinion.
god. This guy's so stupid. Yeah. Why? It's so bad. It's getting
bad, Aiden. I don't even know if I I don't even know if I believe
he believes that. It has to be like bad faith. There's no
shot, dude. There's just no shot. It'd be easy for me to say
he's stupid, but I just think it's like a purposely bad faith.
Seems to be going around recently.
He really thinks his like his son would do that on stream and
then like give you clear signs. That's like what he's doing with
the type of audience he has. Uh yeah, yeah. We just like love
Hitler. Ha ha ha ha ha. That That's what Yes, it's going on,
all We just like love Hitler, you know.
It seems to be the case.
I don't know I don't know specifically what Diorio has said about
his son, but I've heard a lot like there's been this big narr-
like I literally heard people earlier tonight being like, "Yeah,
the whole iDubb's uh video was shut up essentially shut up Jew
or whatever the like perpetuating the narrative like Jew hatred.
Even if, which I don't believe it all, by the way, iDubb and
Hasan genuinely hated Jews or had some negative sentiment towards
Jews, they wouldn't do it in a way where they were aligning like
with Nazis on it. Like they still wouldn't lie Exactly, right?
Yeah, yeah. They're They're not like that. far gone. I understand
people want to pretend the Palestinians are completely great.
Th- These people are not that far gone. That's insane.
It's It's just It's such a It's such a bad faith interpretation.
And then also I I know it sounds good to say, but I know also
um
What's his name? Didn't Wasn't one of the people featured in
iDubb's video, wasn't he Jewish? I know that doesn't necessarily
exempt you from being like anti-Semitic. You can have a token
Jew.
I don't think these people are like Sure, there's like anti-Semitic
narratives being perpetuated by like some of these movements,
but it's
not like They sometimes like they don't even like I don't think
these people are like consciously anti-Semitic
at like at all. They're They're like anti-Israeli.
Yeah, exactly. It's not even anti- It's not anti-Zionist. It's
not anti-Semitic. It's like anti-Israeli. It's very specific.
I don't think they care about American Jews. Uh you know, if
you're not out and out [__] pro-Zionist or some [__]
like that, they don't they don't really care, I think. Exactly.
anti-Israeli specifically. What I mean is like if it's like Ilhan
Omar tweeting about like, "It's all about the Benjamins" or whatever,
she's obviously talking about AIPAC, but people could be like,
"Oh, well, that plays into the narrative about like money or
whatever." The I don't think anyone's like being consciously
or like purposefully in like this movement that's saying anything
that's going to be targeting Jews as like a group. It's It's
anti-Israeli,
And Hasan certainly, even if he did actually believe that, he
would never blame only give it away like that on stream to his
audience.
It would just be insane. Like what They're They're like risking
like what? Getting literally [__] by payment processors
if you start throwing up like swastikas and [__]
Like that's not just
a Twitch ban. That's like MasterCard or pulling support from
here, you know.
Aren't a lot of his audience straight up
Um I don't I don't know if they're really ideologically developed
enough to like call that tankies. A lot of them are. Or or they're
like the USSR or like They're like a lot of tankies.
Yeah, support for Nazism would be like even if you even if you
don't like Jews, supporting Nazism would be like anti-Semitic.
Would they believe it?
I don't know. Dude, that's You should talk to him about that.
That's like such
such I don't think he believes that. I think that's a I think
it's just But this is my thing, right? Is I honestly I don't
know what level of This is why I'm hesitant to saying it cuz
I don't know what level of dishonesty he's operating on cuz this
feels like incredibly dishonest. And if he is just like in full
ball like I'm just going to basically smear and slander, be dishonest,
then he's not going to listen to me and he's just going to try
and Who cares if someone has a swastika on a foam sword?
Well, that's not
No, but like Who cares?
I I think you guys are being fed this by I realize I'm being
fed this by like the super anti- I had to watch his full video
before Friday, so I stayed up late to watch that. I had to watch
um Saint Nicholas Diorio react to it cuz you have to. I had to
watch Local react to it cuz you have to. Yeah. You know, so there's
a lot of content to watch. I'm not Wow.
Saint Nicholas. Saint Nicholas. Is Is Nick like insanely pro-H3
right
Um yeah, I would say so.
I wish old Diorio would struggle coming down a [__]
chimney as well.
I'm pretty sure Santa uses like magic or something. I don't think
he actually goes down them.
I'm making a joke about him getting stuck in a chimney cuz he's
fat.
Good one. What I mean I I just don't think it's realistic. Yeah,
I know that I have to explain everything to you, I got it. Also,
that's not even shaped like a That's not even a swastika as well.
I don't even know why that wasn't the first thing we like pointed
out.
I I mean, it's got some of the same similar shaping and I think
Is the sword like different? I feel like the sword from the anime
I feel like the sword from the anime is way less of a swastika.
The swastika is like just such a like a common I know it's like
associated with more of a swastika. I thought I thought it was
way more of a swastika in the
Like like it actually looked like a swastika, but this This is
like
It's such a common shape across so many cultures. Like it's the
45° angle one that typically or the Do you look at the context
and if it's at a 45° angle,
It's I It's not even like a proper swastika. Like It's all misaligned
and like it's got two like ins in a circles to it sort of thing.
Like it is not a proper swastika. The idea that It's like, "Yeah,
we love Hitler. [__] you." That's not what's happening
here. That's not what they're saying. It's like crazy.
Yeah, I'm sure Hasan went the [__] off about Elon's
salute, right?
I'm almost positive Hasan would have gone the [__]
off about that.
Like I really Hold on. What Maximus, why do you keep linking
this? What is the
Oh, yeah. I guess it's not even technically a swastika. Sure.
Wait, I know. We're all saying it's from Bleach. We all know
it's from Bleach. We've known it's from Bleach for like a I mean,
you showed this picture and then you asked, "Why'd you show it?"
I mean, I'm I'm assuming that's why. asking why he was linking
the Like was he just trying to say it was Bleach? Oh, yeah. I
remember the Nishi thing,
I would assume that's what he's trying to say. Manga? Manga?
Oh, did they not Did they Did they not adapt the swastika to
the anime or
I assume they adapted the swastika to the anime. Okay, so in
Japan
in Japan,
the swastika is in a different direction than the Nazi one, the
same direction the sword is in, and it's called a manji, and
it's meant to signify good luck. Sure, sure, sure.
Wow, it's a Hindu symbol p- Okay, Aiden. Okay. It's It can be
a Hindu symbol piece. It can be It's It's like a shape across
so many different cultures.
um Yeah, it's crazy. I People can't say so. Have you looked into
any of the skull stuff, Jay Stook?
I'm worried the skull things are totally
Yeah, it's the skull thing.
Well, the skulls he got sent to him like some online skull store,
and there's like some Who is people faking harassment? You don't
say. That's wild. Well, they They are real They are real skulls,
though, right?
Somebody had to Like skulls are not cheap, right? Somebody had
to drop like That'd be so awesome to just get free skulls. Free
human skulls.
True. How much Isn't it like five grand or some [__]
Like
I I haven't checked the price of skulls
Who cares? Okay.
Oh, yeah. That was one thing as well. So, this Aristocracy person
who's like a little bit of a a loopy insane pro-Israel person.
Yeah, she's a little bit wacky. Um she she was saying that basically
she had on is is two skulls. Ethan has two kids. I don't think
that's a coincidence. And then Nick replies going, "Oh, yeah.
I think you've got a point there. I didn't even think of that.
And then someone replies to Aris's tweet, Ethan has three kids.
And she's like, oh, right. And then Nick deletes his
Are you No way. serious? No, I'm totally serious. That happened.
Show me. That happened. Show me any proof that that happened.
I don't think so. I think you can't show proof that that happened.
Where is that? Where is it? I believe him. This sounds totally
plausible. I Especially knowing Aristocracy. possibly
She's totally neurotic when it comes to Israel, just like It was
literally on your stream? Well, we covered I covered Nick responding
to Aristocracy. I didn't think it was I don't think we covered
the whole um
that she has she's two kids. Oh, that's a really good point.
I didn't think we covered that.
Real human skulls 2000 1400 1400 1400.
My sleeping schedule is so bad. Isn't it illegal to sell human
bone in my Nope. You're allowed.
Okay, I thought it was only allowed for like universities and
stuff to purchase them. I I didn't know you could just purchase
them as like a random guy. You
All right. Well, I mean
Yeah, I've sold a lot.
Oh, and how did they come Nick, did you Did you not pull up the
screenshot of Nick saying that last night?
Maybe. I thought I pulled up I thought I pulled up a different
tweet. I thought It was just I can't I don't know who [__]
posted it, man.
Maybe the Ethan Klein guy linked it. Hold on. No, someone posted
it in space. I know there was something else that
I pulled something from last night where it was like
they were talking about something.
What was it? It was Aristocracy and Nick. I had it on stream,
but I don't it wasn't that exact thing. I'm almost positive it
was not.
Dude, I I'm trying to think back. I got into an argument with
her about something like a year ago. It was after October 7th.
She said something like so stupid that I If I could just remember
that how it was.
Would Pepsi have posted it? Oh. No, no, sorry. I'm saying I'm
asking who would Pepsi posted it. I'm not sure. I'm I'm scrolling
back through all the images in space chat for last day. I'm scrolling
through it. My bad.
Good luck. You'll be here till like
No, no, no. Here's his tweet. Hold on, someone's linking stuff.
Oh, yeah, Ethan Klein found it. Oh, hold on. I did have this
up on stream. Damn.
This was This was what it was. I was just like, oh, I didn't
even read this. I didn't read the I literally didn't read the
line the child line. I FBI are handling it. He has two children.
I don't think the number was a
I assume the two is in reference to Ethan and Hila. I didn't
even consider his children.
I know.
Oh, no, that's mean. No. No, no.
I'm not doing that.
I I like Nick. He's just
That's not right.
Dude, when Quimbee's not in VC with this guy, he'll go so hard.
And then when Nick is in VC with him, it's just like it's like
he's on a thin go hard on me. Go go hard on Nick. Jason Jason
hard on Nick after stream VC. VC. Oh, only Okay, so
Ah, so we only have Jason talked about God. Yeah, but Nick Nick
doesn't take it personally if you go hard on him in private VC.
If you go in public, he takes it very personally. So, it's still
the same thing. It's still like Klein setting up a business.
It's just a different kind of business. He like so I confronted
It would have to be It would have to be moderated. And also I
would I don't know that I want to do it right now because it
seems like it this guy is like insane at the moment. He's saying
is like the
And there's there's a lot of backing for it, too. So, he's just
going to feel totally If he want If he's in dishonest mode, if
he's just being dishonest, he's trying to people that not people
you know, literally behind me. Um then that's what he's going
to do, right? I can't. So, I actually
Well, when you guys are ready,
I'll uh I'll step in next for the offer.
You can call him out call him out on Twitter right now. I kind
of called him out. I hype I just I threw a little sarcastic comment
in. I don't think it's that big a deal, okay? It's a little sarcastic
What service is being now?
So dumb.
The The Ethan Klein hysteria is just
Someone invite him to this Discord.
I do want to be fair about the skulls thing though, like sure,
people were acting like it was like potentially from like oh,
we don't know where they came from or whatever, but like even
if you're buying them illegally.
Well, no, no, Aiden Aiden, the the thing about the skulls the
skulls are We we don't know they can't confirm
who's even ordered them to that to that place. I don't know,
they had some reason why they can't trace it back to the company,
but if they were ordered from a company and there is People are
saying there's some Teddy Fresh employee that has a bunch of
skull collections posted on Instagram. And so there's there's
just not even any confirmation of who ordered the skulls. It's
the same with the CPS cool where it's just like, I'm getting
harassed. Therefore, it's the responsibility of literally everyone
talking negatively about about me right now. It's the responsibility
of the entire snark Reddit. It's the responsibility of Danems.
It's the responsibility of Ian. It's the responsibility of Hassan.
They're all responsible for my harassment. Every single individual
act is their fault. And that this is just insane capital's reasoning.
So, I just Yeah, I just argued this. I just I thought you were
I thought you were just making a point how like it changes because
they were bought from like a website as a put out No, obviously
it's harassment either way. It would be more threatening if they
were just fresh skulls ripped out of someone's head like
Um but yeah, I was just I was just arguing this point in another
VC how like the long like you're when you're when you have a
platform with so many people, you're going to you're bound hypothetically,
which we don't have evidence of as you said, this did come from
like an H3 snarker or whatever the
when you're when you have such a large audience, there's just
bound to be like a few schizos that are going to do things that
you never called for that If you keep spazzing out about it,
it's not going to stop. Yeah, we don't hold this standard for
like anybody else like ever. Yeah. Yep. It's just people just
allowing it to be done here because they hate the people he's
going against. It's like getting insane at this point.
Uh this is a funny argument. I think this is a this is a funny
argument, to be honest. Hila Klein is being shamed for her mandatory
military service. Why are people like Dan, Sasan, Items, and
Frogan not criticized harder for paying taxes? By sending money
to Hassan on stream, a percentage of your subscription is being
sent to the US government and therefore to Israel.
I think the only ethical way to support Hassan would be canceling
your subscriptions until he stops paying taxes in protest.
I think it's just like a funny Writing homes in the West Bank
is the exact same as paying taxes, actually. These are the same
thing. These are the exact same thing. Where was she
Did she actually raid homes in the West Bank? Yeah, she described
raiding a home in the West Bank. She did not go into the home.
Did she not Did she still not say that she was with them and
they they found guns?
I thought I thought she was in the car the whole time. My understanding
is that she said that they went into a home, they found guns,
and that she was like, well, this is surreal. It could be that
she was in the car the whole time. That could be totally true.
And they brought out the guns and she it's just the phrasing.
But that that was the clip I heard. Could be totally clipped.
I wouldn't commit anything to it. That that's what I heard the
other day.
Pretty pretty sure it was them saying the car. It seems like
a lot of people are saying Well, she she she describes finding
guns. She describes them finding guns, I think under a bed or
something.
Someone should be I goes all crazy. I'm good with just I'm good
with You know what? I just every time I get in an argument over
this stuff, I'm like, I need to see literally the primary source
Hila Klein described IDF right. Let's see. I can't trust literally
anybody's just recollection of these things because it is poisoned.
Always trust my recollection of things cuz I've never been wrong.
Uh-huh. Okay.
I've never been wrong. ever.
You're never wrong, Kelly. That's what I said. Name a time Kelly's
ever been wrong. Can't do it. Nobody can do it. You can't do
it. Can't be done.
He's hesitant to join.
The timestamp here is in this video.
I don't know if you all wind it back a little bit more. I've
just sort of gone to the transcript and found it, so.
Rounded women.
Actually, I was sent a clip earlier today. I just got to I want
to watch this first.
Some equally neurotic Jewish kid was getting really really pissy
about
someone's ability to run clips on their Check this out real quick.
right now. You're doing it for the state. He's doing this No,
no, no. I realize I'm doing it cuz of you. That's why. Actually,
you know, I'm going to bathroom. Kelly, entertain the stream
for a second. Let's go.
Oh, why?
Let's watch this clip in a minute. He's saying he's bad and saying
he's Yeah, no, he's an He's an [__] and he pays the
tax the time tax.
He is.
When does that happen?
I was the IRS you'd be in jail for It's it's when I apologize
for being an adult Kelly that's when I he'll never apologize
to me so I have to tax him this way.
Are we good?
So are you saying Cenk Uygur will never apologize for being an
He won't. Did you have a gun on you? I didn't.
I mean I walked with them to one house. Okay. I did get out of
the car once. But but surrounded with them so Okay. Did they
arrest anyone that night? They did. Did they bring it Hold on.
I think we get I think we pretty easily say that she got out
of the car it seems like it's not even a little bit ambiguous.
That she got out of the car. She said she got out of the car
so she didn't stay in the car everyone's saying that
No I'm not. All I say all I say is let me look at the primary
evidence okay? Give me the primary evidence and that's all I
want. I thought she literally said she entered a home.
No yeah not really but even if I I mean I walked with them to
one house. Okay. I did get out of the car once. But but surrounded
with them so Okay. Did they arrest anyone that night? They did.
Did they bring it in the same car with you? No. They got there's
a few cars going. I don't know if hold on I don't know if she
raided a home sounds like she walked into the She walked with
them to the
quite key distinction actually.
Well what happens
What would happen if she stayed in the
Nothing. She was there for a ride along she just like went along
Would be considered like disobe orders from like a superior or
something? No I don't know if she was ordered to obviously we
don't No but my understanding is she basically volunteered she
wanted to go and do this with them. I got it.
I finished the clip.
Are you think it's crazy? It's crazy. What was it like how did
you feel was it horrifying?
It was strange.
very weird. How's it like how's it so I was a lazy speaker.
No you know what Kelly did you have a point you wanted to make
there Kelly? She didn't move her mouth already Kelly. Oh that
was we don't need to hear what she's saying so cuz she doesn't
move her mouth. I can't hear what she's saying.
Kelly Kelly
She's lazy with her mouth moving.
I'm saying she is specifically lazy when she speak.
I don't tell me to shut up.
I don't know just Don't tell me to shut up. You see people in
the house and then it's like
The soldiers go just walk into the house
Thanks Kelly thank you thank you Kelly. You don't
I totally misheard your client there hold on a second.
I rolled it I rolled it back about 15
I don't know just
You see people in the house and then it's like
The soldiers go just walk into the house
Look through their and find guns.
I was in
The whole thing is really surreal.
So she so so she got out of the car went with soldiers and they
raided the house. I don't think saying she raided the house is
really that far from the reality. I don't think taking that from
that clip is actually that crazy.
Do they need want something in that clip? I'm just laughing about
Kelly
Look through their
God Kelly please.
You have a right to tell me to shut up. Because we're trying
to get the information out Kelly then we can move on and you
can say whatever you want. Information out? No I can say what
I want whenever I want.
That's true.
Do not do not tread Cenk Uygur do not tread on Kelly Jean's rights
to speak.
I don't know just
You see people in the house and then it's like
The soldiers go just walk into the house
Look through their and find guns and
It's like crazy. You're like so obnoxious on Kelly.
Kelly owns you. Ow my [__] ribs. Jesus Christ.
Oh [__]
Oh this is the best part of the stream is when other people join
and realize that I like almost lost it like eight times tonight
and then I get to watch one other person experience it for like
10 minutes. I actually should just end stream we didn't we didn't
make the goal for another for an eighth hour in stream but just
watching some other people have to deal with it. Oh.
So so can we can we just get an agreement here what did hear
the client go on a raid of a house? Was she accompanying a raid
on a house in the West Bank?
I don't know about that.
Did they go into a house? Was she accompanying a raid? Yes. On
a house in the West Bank. Was she accompanying a raid on a house
in the West Bank? Yes.
Yes. Okay. But wait my other question would be why this
Why this house in particular? Were they just searching random
houses?
I think they just go and harass the locals yeah. No I know they
do I know they do I know they do.
I'm just to play devil's advocate. No actually I don't need to
play devil's advocate. Yeah she probably raided a civilian's
house.
I mean I don't know like I doubt she you know I doubt she held
a gun to like a Palestinian woman's like head with her children
there trembling you know. No obviously not.
But she did go on a raid on a house in the West Bank like that
that is what happened very clearly. They raided the And she didn't
just sit in the car that she like walked She didn't just sit
in the car. I'd say I'd probably say cuz
Yeah that it doesn't really make the distinction the way you're
saying it
Cuz she did accompany in the one raids.
You guess say that she left the car she didn't just sit in the
car.
Did we know it was a raid? What if it was like a charitable act
cleaning the house of some civilians and they happen to find
a gun?
She was ra
She said it was a raid yeah.
Maybe in their language that means a favor.
Well you would know. I was there at your bar mitzvah didn't you
have to learn some of it?
Yeah so true.
Wait I'm not joking.
No I did not.
I should.
Not by religion.
Crazy. You're not ethnically Jewish. Yeah and there's no you
don't there's Obviously but And in the Jewish religion that's
the same like there's no distinguishing in that regard. Is there
another kind?
What's the other third kind of Jewish? It's an ethnicity and
it's a religion. Yes the third one. What do you mean? I said
to Cenk Uygur what's the other one? He didn't say there was a
third one. He never said there was a third one. What's the third
kind of Jew?
I was speaking to Cenk Uygur because he said he stated the obvious.
And that's why I said oh what's the A Jew a Jew by behavior.
It's like
You guys you guys think we could qualify Nicholas as aspirationally
Jewish at this point?
Yeah wait wait wait wait hold on let me ask. Cenk Uygur do you
think do you think Willy's criticisms of me were were good? Do
you think they're solid?
I don't remember what he said but I said you got right.
You didn't watch the video you you you didn't watch the video
and you and you admitted you didn't watch the video and that's
just an L and you got owned.
Wait hold on I said I said I said I watched the sections that
I criticized
You just cut it Yeah but unfortunately that's that's you lost.
Wasn't missing information on what he talked about at all.
But yeah I guess if you say by the way that whole I'll just say
the whole reason I made that was to be like I'm actually not
going to go after Willy for this and I like I communicated poorly
I was trying to be humble.
He spat in your face. Never make that mistake again. Never make
that mistake
Next time a rape freak's called don't say well hold on we should
try to Destiny instead.
You should get a real life like Willy
He's very normal I've heard. He is I've heard that too. Did you
see Nick's Reddit comment that was like I thought everyone had
a normal reaction to this video.
No dude I was going to give the my biggest criticism my biggest
criticism for Nick I'll go check my Twitter
And he's always on it and I'm like is that is this like an old
tweet and it's like every hour
He's tweeting but apparently he's also posting on Reddit and
it's like when is this guy Is there ever a moment of the day
where this guy is not typing?
Like if you look at like his posting
You can get mad at Nick, but he is on the ball. He knows what's
going on,
Guy's not He was he was deleting Reddit posts about Liquid Sonics
Willy Mac video when that came out. It's very funny. I am pro
censorship, so that is based, but Oh, also
You guys saw that the Glitch Poachers guy let Willy get around
the Erudite thing though, right? Or wait, has Willy admitted
that he got help from Erudite? I think he has a point, right?
Right, I think he he probably knows he probably spoke to her.
I don't know if he admitted that admit the [__] look
I thought he said that or maybe Erudite said I gave Willy Mac
like help with his video or something.
Is that what the funny one where he goes like, "No, no, no, I
didn't get Destiny doesn't say anything about my videos." And
it's like, "Well, well,
I could have I could have sworn you guys called this person Ghislaine
Maxwell or something, right?"
What about that one? Not So no, Jeffrey Epstein had no input
on anything I did. Ghislaine Maxwell? Well, a little bit. A little
bit.
That Glitch Poachers guy is a idiot.
He is.
Wait, was NSE even in the Willy video? Uh no, she just helped
him with it.
You got to say this, but then you won't say when any of the details
of that are. That is very cringe.
Cuz I would like them to I would like them to go, "No, no, no,
that didn't
Who are you protecting?
Then why wouldn't you just say who and He got the information
from he got it from the he got it from the Jew network, okay?
I'm protecting Jews. I'm going to put them in my attic. No, you
you gave me the information. Don't let him get away with that,
Kelly. Wait, Queenan, expose the expose Wait, where did I
Call J Star's number is this. Don't call that number. What the
[__]
That's weird. Time that guy out. Get that guy out of here.
It's crazy number to say.
I just follow That's weird. Uh 813-630-0707
is apparently where that is. I wouldn't read that out.
Why not? Because that could be someone's dogs.
Just leave that number there lonely.
I don't know I don't know where it's It's a pizza place.
Listen, I don't recognize that number. I don't know where that
number is from.
What's an 831 area Yeah, that's what I thought. I thought 800s
That's why I said that. I thought 800s That's a gentleman's club.
Wait, it's asking
what the Erudite information was and you won't give it. So, Queenan
said he got the info from you. So, what was it?
Said Willy helped.
So, wait, Erudite What was it? What are the details of this?
How do you know this?
Uh why would I say that? I don't get information from people.
What are you talking about? Because you're being a
Yeah, I Why would people give me information if I just rat them
out the second they give me information, Kelly?
Is it the second or is it like I always I always wait until I
have two sources for the same piece of information at least,
and then I'll say
And then I have plausible deniability for those people, okay?
Uh-huh.
Well, I figured out what the number was. It's for a It's for
a strip club. It's for a strip club in Tampa, Florida.
Oh, you did?
You never Nobody said that. Gentleman's club? Do you remember
gentleman's club being said?
No. Multiple times? No, okay. It was. No. No. Thank you. Now,
you lost Aiden. Thank you. Thank you. Just lying, gaslighting?
It's okay. I'll let you get away with it. You get one free pass.
Uh okay.
Is it a hate crime to gaslight a Jew?
Yes. Yes. It's an e-holocaust.
It's like what Twitch did to Dan Saltman. It's the funniest people
have got I saw someone call Ethan Klein the Bel-Air pogroms.
Yeah, it's true.
machine. Raul wants me to watch next. who has given Dan Saltman
optical
Oh, let's let's look and see.
It's studio. That's Destiny's media Not a single dollar. Again,
why would he pay me to make him look I spoke to him and I'm like,
"Listen, Is that why Dan said that in the background?
Wait, that's why Dan came in here and said that. Oh, this makes
so much more sense now. I get it. Oh, since Nick is
When you start the initial statement you have to say before anyone
gets to you [__] hate Jews. Considering some of the
other behind-the-scenes conversation the criticism there. What
Wait, what did I do wrong? who has given Dan Saltman optical
Okay, he gave Dan Saltman optical advice. It'll come after it's
right after the number. I spoke to him and I'm like, "Listen,
the problem with you and and Yeah, I'm turning the sound up for
a
Wait, are you trying to say that I gave him advice
after I mauled him on stream for Oh, why are they Why didn't
go? on him? You bullied him? Yeah, and I said that
like after the stream.
Cuz I'm talking about it in past tense. But like Erudite and
Dan stupid. Oh, since Nick is Deorio has given Dan Saltman What
is What good is Optics advice after he's already said everything?
optical advice. And I've been quoting it ever since. But I spoke
to him and I'm like, "Listen, the problem with you and and Erudite
is you guys knew for months so you come to terms with this and
you've engaged with it. That's not what the public wants to hear
a day after they find out. Like I'm acknowledging the fact that
they came out and immediately made these statements, right? Is
that Is that Oh, he's already watched the clip. Oh, is it before
this? My bad. Minus 4 minutes.
I just want to end up with her. Very odd to me. questions knowing
the input on knowing what kind of input Wait, where the where
the [__] is it?
What do you mean minus 4 minutes? Raul, what are you talking
about? Thanks, Raul. Thanks, Raul. It's somewhere around here.
Hold on. guy with his company you speak out
larger than Willy's.
Well, I'll just see if I can find I thought it was after the
list. to more people than Willy's going to see in a
Why can't we ask him questions? Or when you befriend someone
like Mr. Girl, it doesn't really matter if you speak out against
touching kids. Oh, what do you What do you say about this one
would be an interesting one. Queenan is making violent remarks
towards another Twitter account who simply
Why Why you always get me in trouble, Queenan? What the [__]
wrong with you?
Listen, you have to be nice. I didn't even I DIDN'T EVEN SAY
ANYTHING HERE, by the way, and he blames me. He's like, "These
guys are making violent remarks." I literally was like, "No,
I don't think that's what's going on here." to J Star and Queenan
to make any arguments. Like, I'm sorry, you've made the negative
argument that I dislike.
You were not allowed to have that
that even when they're being threatened with their docs. Notice
how he doesn't mention the death threats. I can't help but notice
how big of Like I don't understand. Do you have to be nice to
J Star and Queenan to make any arguments? Like, I'm sorry, you've
made the negative argument that I dislike.
This is the guy who called me BPD and lost his mind
over me apparently running and a bunch of other bizarre things
about me being mind
and being so like functionally underdeveloped that talking to
me is like some kind of that I I don't know.
And then he come into VC to talk to me whatsoever.
And then he had to leave all the servers where I tagged him and
called him fat.
Wait, wait, wait. We'll pull up the stream. We'll pull up the
stream. We'll pull up the stream in chat right now. I need to
see that. Immediately, Ethan Klein is is bringing us potentially
vital information here. Well, we'll check it out. I'm just going
to finish the Nick clips and then we'll do that. Okay, I got
it. I got to load it up, all right?
Okay, can we Yeah.
Got to load it up. not allowed to have that opinion. He wants
me to pearl clutch over Destiny's violent remarks. When the tweet
I'm quoting, Queenan is making violent remarks towards another
Twitter account who simply posted my
hack loser, right? He needs to be like absolutely kicked into
the dirt. I think he just hates his son. But he needs to be stomped
into the the This guy want to say that. These guys say violent
things just like Destiny. They were huge fans of him up until
recently. I don't
Okay, Willy did you there though.
Who was recently? Like 2 years ago?
Yeah, I mean I remember I had to get permission for Queenan to
come on
by that point he was He was already known as like a
So, I had to speak to Kuran Ton and then check pumped out like
a whole a whole month's worth of content with divorce. So, I
mean, yeah, that would probably probably do that. I don't think
Queenan was ever a huge fan of Destiny, right? I mean, well,
I I was like 3 years ago. I think he was always fairly critical.
I don't think he was DK, but I think he was critical. Anyone
in any actual how to
critical. Queenan, that was the final straw 3 years ago. The
stuff that really pushed me over was the capital stuff when he
said he was going to sue a bunch people and get retractions and
start business. And I was like, "Wow, this guy's a loser."
He was like he was talking about all this. He was like claiming
he was going to fight for, you know, all this internet [__]
where he was going to make sure Keemstar doesn't die and he was
going to fight the Clownfish and get retractions from all these
journalists of what Keemstar did to Keemstar. He did none of
it cuz he's And now he's the exact same doing the exact same
[__] trying to make everything suck. Cuz he's lazy
and cheap. I got the the the vibe that he wasn't like a DGG writer.
I think he was a massive fan. Oh, I don't know then. Four or
five years ago Okay, then I have no But if they feel like they
are, they should thank me for giving them the warning and call
the cops. He says I'm downplaying Destiny's crimes for predicting
I didn't I was never mad at Willy for publishing that video.
What?
What he Thank you for the warning. that his career won't end
over this. You told me, right? But I've never seen someone's
career end All right, we got this thing right here
argument is that I like what Destiny did to Jeffrey Epstein.
Especially when we're talking about a guy with the nickname Epstiny.
When Jay Stoks says Destiny has created a machine. I think one
of the big I mean a massive talking point here is the infinite
machine. Okay, but does the infinite machine work? You guys make
what The infinite machine. It's like the water source in Minecraft.
This is so unserious, man. I'm so This is the level you have
to criticize Destiny, otherwise you're sweeping. Destiny actually
did wrong. But I
Why why can't anybody rapes completely different I can't anybody
Yeah, why can't anybody actually critically engage with anything?
It's crazy.
I can't wait for this to be like, "Wow, this video was fantastic
until he spent like 10 minutes talking about somebody who wasn't
Destiny."
We needed more Kelly Jean in this video.
Rent [__] free, you stupid The issue was The issue
is now that he's spent time talking about things with Destiny.
Because Destiny didn't anybody. He didn't traffic anyone. He
broke people's trust who were intimate with him so he could the
19-year-old e-girl leading to these people's images being forever
cemented online.
Your employees were kids, their family members You notice right
there I I'm pretty confident that he thinks um the cherry stuff
was from the Rose leaks.
Do you catch that? Well, I mean that's to be like, "Wow,
God, I'm putting It's like kind of instant consequential. It's
just funny.
on my list. All right, okay. How much more of this do we need
to see because I'm dying to see that stream of war right now.
Uh I have no idea. This video was fantastic until he spent like
10 minutes talking about somebody who wasn't
We needed more Kelly Jean in this video. what Destiny actually
did wrong seemed not that bad because Destiny didn't anybody.
He didn't traffic anyone. He broke people Do you think Nick and
and Willy would have this criticism for Do you watch the Chud
clip? thumbnails
Uh well, yeah, and Chud just broadly basically blowing the [__]
out or blowing people the [__] out who made this
exact criticism. They're like, "You can't call it It's not actually
And Chud just started screaming at them that they're absolutely
they're in waiting.
Uh it was a good clip. Hold on. Let me find it. I think Windy
sent it to me.
Uh this one Uh this one. Okay. Uh it was a good clip. Hey, hey,
you're you're absolutely re-looping right now.
You See, this is the other problem, too. You get these people
and they engage in this malicious skepticism where every piece
of information is scrutinized to absurdity. Bender became a member.
Banana Bender celebrates months of membership, but Debate Me
Bro streamer got exposed for secretly recording a woman's obfuscation
of membership.
and this I'm actually experienced. Literally don't care about
victims. So, you know, good luck next time. But I don't care
about victims where you're going to be able to moralize because
I'm calling you apologist. You are apologist and that's the end
of it. And there's literally nothing you can do to stop me thinking
that because that is what I believe. He just repeatedly claims
that the main purpose of the statement was about preventing me
Uh why deep think of the eight months.
Okay. All right.
Oh, it was a Red Bar clip. Red Bar Red Bar sent the skulls to
you. in his car. Skeletons, people love a skeleton. Now, we do
have a few skulls here, too. Mhm. Big deal. Okay, we didn't go
overboard with the skull.
Okay, well, this wasn't that wasn't
This Ethan Klein chatter. You you got my
I bought it on the You really believe them when he said there's
100% proof that Red Bar sent the skulls. You are I know you want
to say something
He was saying he He was saying for sure. He said that guy said
earlier for sure. He said something regarding Hila Klein specifically.
He told you last night that you know that that's the Indian guy
with the Indian accent who comes in and trolls every single time.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Sometimes he has to Sometimes he's the He's the
right Sometimes he has good stuff. Sometimes he has good stuff.
This Quimbee guy hates Indians. It's like insane.
No, this guy does an Indian accent. He's not Indian.
I got owned. Yeah, he came in and just did his saying the [__]
with an Indian accent. He's like, "Quimbee, I'm going You It's
just like Yeah, that that guy.
Here's your clip starting at the current Is this What is that?
I'm not Indian, am I? Oh, wait. This is the same thing as before.
Never mind. We clicked it. We went through it.
Okay. All right. I think I think that's Your British accent is
bad, so I would I wouldn't take shots at my Indian accent,
Oh, wait. What time is it? I've got to try to do some other stuff
up here.
One day someone will make me laugh like intentionally as much
as they make me laugh unintentionally.
Oh. It'll be me.
I'm the comedy king.
You sound like you should be getting ready for school.
Is anyone online right now?
We got here.
Resi's online. He's watching the video.
All right. I'm going to send you guys over to Resi. We'll talk
to you all
Have a good night, everybody.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
Good night.
It was a gay outro.
Absolutely absolutely gay outro. Sorry, I'm uh